والعامل الاساسي هو الطائفه والمذهبي ايضا
لانه تغيير الطبيعه على مستوى اسرائيل في
عندهم معوقات معوقات دينيه يعني فينا نقول
لحازم انه انه نحن العرب بشكل عام بشكل
عام عم بحكي
محاصرين
بمثلث من من انظمه عند طموح طموح
امبراطوري يعني امبراطوريات بائده عم ترجع
تحيي نفسها بطرق مختلفه منها الامبراطوريه
التركيه
بلباس كمان مذهبي اخواني بمقدار ما
الامبراطوريه الفارسه بلباس مذهبي ايضا
والامبراطوريه النظريه نظريا التوراتيه
اللي هي تحدثت عنها اللي هي قيام ونحن
داخل هذا المثلث فينا نوصف هذا يعني اكيد
مع
بوليسيه مع بالعشره 15 سنه الاخيره مع
صعود الشعبوات
والتراجع
لاصاب من جهه اصاب
ديمقراطيه من جهه ثانيه اصاب التاثير
الغربي
من جهه اصاب الاحتكام الى السياسه
وصار احتكام اكثر للقوه كتير هالمشاريع
الامبراطوريه المجهضه رفعت راسها وعبرت عن
حالها يعني مثلا
كثير له معنى انه واحد مثلنا ثاني ياهو
يحكم
واحد مثل اردوغان اردوغان من المتصور 2002
يغير يغير في الاسس الديمقراطيه البلد
الايراني باخر امر على تغييرات الواجهه
يعني
غالبا رئيس جمهوريه بتغير بس النظام كان
نظام التسعه واربعين موجود من التسعه
وسبعين حكم رجال الدين
[موسيقى]